thank you
[Music]
a Japanese tourist beats up a Korean cab
driver for not knowing Japanese
well what do you guys say in Korea yeah
dude defend your people go ahead die
serves him right no I don't know that's
[__] up that's crazy yeah in Korea so
there was a drunken Japanese tourist and
the taxi driver the Korean Taxi Driver
said it was because he couldn't
understand what the [__] he's saying
um the man started to assault him yeah
yeah
um so the man apparently has a a strong
physique he throws a man to the floor he
punches the follow man gets up and kicks
him and when people passing by are like
what's going on
um he starts [__] them up well no he
just keeps on going and the man who hit
was this Japanese tourist in his 20s
who's drunk and after he gets into the
taxi he he assaulted the driver while
talking in Japanese and during the
interrogation with the police later the
perpetrator said that he had not
understood the words and hit him
it's good reason though you know how
frustrated he is to like try to talk to
somebody they don't understand what
you're trying to say it's difficult for
the sake of um just being just being an
ally to all ages oh yeah go ahead for
the sake of being an ally to all agents
I think this is uh it's important to
especially with their history and not
focus or hyper focus on the fact that
one was Korean one was Japanese because
that's such like a historically like
crazy
um history it should be more like a
drunk man was being drunk and assaulted
a cab driver you know what I'm saying he
wasn't just drunk he's drunk while
Japanese yeah that's two infractions
while in Seoul two cats you know a lot
of times like something happens that
like uh that that could happen to any
people but then it's like a Japanese man
did this to a Korean and it's like
that's such a yeah that's such a thick
concept you know I think we should pick
my great grandpa colonized uh their
country you know I love Seoul that's all
I could say big fan the story reminded
me of yesterday where Joe's like yes
Korean Grandma [__] hated me because
I'm jumping companies and I was like
whoa this is kind of a crazy story to
read like two hours later and you're
like I can see why they hate you that's
kind of interesting it's kind of [__]
up what you did Joe he was obviously
yeah exactly he's drunk and then um yeah
you just started throwing balls at this
cat because he couldn't understand a
[__] word that's [__] up dude he
didn't even try to cover it up with the
police though man he's insult yeah give
a different excuse that's a bad excuse
that's like me just being in Puerto
Vallarta and I'm wailing some Mexican
cab driver because he doesn't speak
English and then you say that to the
Mexican police because then you but then
you'd be like oh [__] the Mexican police
are gonna hear that and beat my ass now
right yeah that's exactly what you think
the authorities are on my side he should
have spoke English because everyone
speaks English out there that's pretty
true it's a second language like
everywhere because we killed it so hard
you gotta admit boys I hear soul is like
a really big like Party Town like a lot
of people drink eat yeah like they eat
good [__] Fried Chicken over there
and they go over there and party so you
think this Japanese dude couldn't handle
[__] soul he couldn't handle the
party life I think that was so drunk he
probably thought he was back in Japan
and he's all like what the [__] is this
cab driver saying can't handle Korea
dude did the Japanese guy have like
tattoos all over him he's like yeah was
he missing fingers yeah he's like one of
them yeah I just checked it says yeah
it's amazing
it really just sounds like a super drunk
because usually Japanese
stereotypically tourists are so polite
so I'll tell you put alcohol in their
body then they turn British oh and then
they turn Irish it's funny because this
same situation would happen here between
two people that just have different
accents you know I can understand what
you're [__] saying
we should focus more on the Japanese and
Korean yeah yeah I think so to the
people angry we should sensationalize it
if we can we should like create beef and
make you like a German Japanese guy
beats up a Jewish Korean guy yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it's the relationship a little bit more
applicable too it just like really Bart
said this morning he's like I want to
play the game in 2023 good for you oh
Bart said I was gonna wait till next
year but I'm doing it this year yeah he
lied to us he said he's only doing it
for barbell he brought it to JK today
hey thanks man good guy man thank you to
that we knew that boost it's good man
yeah I think it's good to focus on that
did you guys know that um Korea used to
be spelled with a c so then when the
Japanese took it over they changed to a
k so that it would come later in the
alphabet after J is that true if that's
true how come they didn't change it to a
c after Japanese people laughed they
doubled down and we're like KP baby and
they kept the king because Japanese
people were trying to spell the sea
though yeah Japanese people were trying
to erase their history and and straight
up as if like Korean had never existed
when they were like taking over people
at the time crazy they were erasing
history they're going to libraries
they're burning documents they were
burning historical things that would
like protect and you know whatever was
original to Korean tradition wow so they
even wanted to go so far as change the
name of the country and then after that
it was widely accepted because Japan was
so you know
prosperous everywhere else that they're
the history writers yeah they wrote that
Korea was spelled with the K and that's
what held and stuck because it wasn't
about changing your back that's crazy
that is nuts man it's not like Koreans
at the time were spelling with like uh
Alpha like letters that much right it
was more like the way that the world uh
accepted it yeah right right that's
crazy you know what the worst part about
this because like I was reading this
like late last night and the worst part
about this is that this guy was using
Taekwondo
oh he's appropriate was the other guy
doing karate yeah
Aikido the Korean guy didn't do anything
he was a [__] yeah you know you know be
really cool reparations for this for the
letter thing is if Korea's like from now
on your Japanese
way in the back
that means so now a picture you're on a
road trip
you're playing The Alphabet game
it's gonna take a long time to get there
included three flights sometimes it's
gonna take for a little Joey even more
it's gonna be an exclamation they're
gonna push it even more
they're not even gonna let you be on the
[__] alphabet they're gonna push you
to one of the other tanks you're an
asterisk before Japanese
game day after Christmas day go like
this I'll tell you this so so you are on
the road and you can only you you can
you have to look for things that are of
the letter that you're on so like a
right okay cool Arco
Arco but if if I call Arco Nikki doesn't
call it she has to find something else
on a still or when do you move to B no
she's on a so the I got my a Arco she's
waiting for a so she's like a and p.m
and then like ah [__] we're both on B
right oh but like let's say you're like
Arco she can't find an aim then you're
like bank so now you're on scene no
you're getting your head yeah got it and
then the Winner's the one who gets to
zip yeah
Japanese guy yeah
decal custom decal Japanese car yeah you
need it you need it but it can't be it
has to have the name in it so you're
pretty [__] Zeppelin's car there's
that game I was about to kill this [__]
I'm gonna kill her she's good I bet
she's real good and she's driving too so
I was like I had all the advantages I
got like 90 degree angle and I'm like I
can look everywhere around me and she's
like that one that one that one I'm like
oh this [__]
were you in the deserts yeah desert
nowhere no nowhere and she was still
fighting yeah she's still fine it's a
Corolla she's like oh yeah [__] um
elaris or whatever I'm like God damn it
how did I miss that [__] and I'm like oh
yeah I don't have my glasses on I'm like
I'm [__]
yeah that's uh it's a handicap a little
bit yeah that'll do it dude have you
guys uh been in to like [__] up
situations by being like too drunk or
like like ever a violent situation
because like
like I stopped going out because it was
even if like my friends were like that
or like people around me were like that
so I'm like I don't want to deal with
this [__] no more
but yeah yeah that only happened when I
was around very very particular
uh friends of mine you know what I mean
because then you go to those scenes and
that type of attitude is apparent with
those like types of people it happens
with a bunch of different races where
they like drink liquid courage they
gotta puff their chest up now they'll
look hard in front of their homies or
other girl or whatever dude I saw some
trash families fight at [__] Dave and
Buster dude they got it was over there
and they were like Asians I don't like
it when there's like tension in there I
don't like that yeah that's like going
to Waffle House at two in the morning
and you'll see people fight well that's
a squared Circle I mean that's different
yeah that's the ring yeah that's the
[__] octave you're going in because
you've been training for months yeah
yeah you're ready to [__] that's like
I'm being a soccer hooligan but for
America yeah that's a Coliseum as far as
I'm concerned they said in Bruce Lee's
Game of Death the very top of the Pagoda
is a Waffle House Full House after
Kareem yeah there was one and if you win
you get hash browns with onions and
gravy on top what a prize that's how
Bruce Lee died you lose you die you
wouldn't do a Waffle House tired that's
what I heard
he was tired as hell
because I do like I do like nightlife I
like people watching like even though I
don't drink like that just watching
people go out and then like oh actually
I think it's hilarious but then like
there's always fights that there's
always trouble there's always something
shootouts oh God you know and then
you're just like
never mind or what's what might be even
worse is the guy who's like really
friendly and he's drunk but he's like
too friendly shut the [__] up and you're
like all right bro he starts making out
with you it doesn't touch you a lot
you're like all right dude let me pulls
your pants down yeah and then he the
next thing you know we're in the men's
bathroom together
you let it there
[Music]